Hey, David, between the legal challenges and
the not conceding and claiming he won and
lawsuits and electoral ideas, what is Donald
Trump's actual end game here?
Does he think he will be inaugurated to a
second term?
I think the answer is no.
I think at this point, Donald Trump knows
he's not getting a second term.
And for me, you know, there's been a lot of
focus about Trump's lawsuits having the goal
of throwing out so-called illegal votes or
getting a recount that changes the results.
I think if we want to for a second believe
that there's some bigger strategy here and
there may not be, but let's imagine there
is some bigger strategy.
The more likely strategy, the more likely
to be effective strategy here would be that
Donald Trump is merely trying to get a court
to prevent a state from certifying its election.
If you can prevent state legislatures from
certifying the election results, you then
can create a situation where state legislators
get to pick electors.
This is part of three USC Section two.
Now, this is different than what I talked
about in an earlier segment where I said you're
not going to get enough faithless electors.
You're not going to get willy nilly states
to just send different electors.
But there's this scenario where if you can
actually delay certification, state legislatures
get to appoint electors.
And for me, if there is a strategy and I don't
know that there is these people have shown
themselves to be incompetent.
Everything they're filing is being thrown
out.
If there were a strategy, it would be that
I still think it's unlikely because I don't
know that I see a court staying, in other
words, pausing certification by any state
in such a way that it will go further than
roughly December 14th, which is when that
electoral vote is set to happen.
I don't see that happening.
Courts have been moving very quickly, oftentimes
will have a lawsuit and then two days later,
the court throws it out.
Courts understand the time sensitivity of
this.
So given that, I don't think Trump really
believes he has a shot at overturning the
election results, it seems to me that this
is either just Donald Trump's delusional,
narcissistic ego who can't admit that he lost,
even if he sort of knows he knows he's going
to be pushed out.
He simply can't admit it.
And he says, file every lawsuit.
You can do everything you can.
It might simply be that it could be Donald
Trump planning to undermine Joe Biden not
only now, but through his presidency.
And this is just part of it.
Never admitting that he actually lost it could
be that Donald Trump is trying to hand Joe
Biden the most chaotic possible situation
he can on January 20th.
And continuing to further these lawsuits is
part of that.
And it could be that Donald Trump is simply
trying to smoothly transition right into some
kind of media project, which has been hypothesized
by many.
Trump wants to do some kind of challenger
to Fox News, some kind of outfoxing Fox News
with some kind of Trump news network.
All of these things I find myself saying,
OK, we'll deal with that one when we come
to it, if we do after Donald Trump has left
office on January 20th.
But I don't see any end game beyond that.
And if you really think Donald Trump is doing
this because he thinks he's going to get a
second term, I want to hear from you.
I just don't see it.
We have a great bonus show for you today,
after which we will be off Thursday and Friday
for Thanksgiving.
I will be back with you on Monday, Monday.
Have a good holiday.
If you're celebrating, be safe.
Very important.
Be safe.